زينوا شوارع البلاد استعدادا لبطوله كاس
العالم هنا البرازيل مصدر الماده الخام
لمواهب كره القدم
اولئك اللاعبين الذين يمتعون الجماهير
بفنهم الساحر فهل يفعلها نيمار واصدقائه
ويمنحون بلدهم فرحه لقب سادس لا تنسى
[موسيقى]
في مدينه ساول مثلا امتزج اللونان الاصفر
والاخضر في شوارع الاحياء الفقيره فهؤلاء
ينتظرون خبرا طارا انتظاره قد خطه اقدام
نيمار ورفاقه
عصام
المنتخب
كره القدم عبر التاريخ
5 القاب وكؤوس من الذهب تفوق بها راقص
سامبا على كل من المانيا وايطاليا التي
تحتلان المرتبه الثانيه باربعه القاب لكل
منهما ومنذ تحقيق لقب كاس العالم عام 94
وتقليد تزيين الشوارع في البرازيل مستمر
احتفاء بقدوم البطوله وهو ما يعتبر عيدا
بالنسبه له فهنا يتوقف كل شيء من اجل 90
دقيقه وهي تعني لهم كل شيء
تقليد وتزيين الشوارع في البرازيل يشهد
تنافسا بين السكان للفوز بجواء ازاله
لاكثر التصميمات ابداعا الشوارع في
ساوباولو تلون احتفاء بالبطوله منذ عام
تزيين الشوارع لدى البرازيليين له رسائل
عده وبعض الرسامين يريدون ايصال رساله
للاعبي المنتخب مفادها اننا نفعل ما
بوسعنا في شوارعنا المتواضعه وعليكم انتم
بذل المزيد من الجهد على العشب الاخضر
مراره السباعيه امام الماكينه الالمانيه
اغنيه
قدمتها للعالم بعبقريتها الخاصه لاعبون
امثال بيليه ريفيلينو زيكو سقراط كاريكا
وروماريو رونالدو رونالدينيو ونيمار
على القوه البدنيه
فالبرازيل عبر تاريخها الكروي تلعب لتمتعه
وتقنعه قبل ان تلعب على مبدا المكسبي او
الخساره